بعد فشل النظام الايراني بقمع الاحتجاجات
المتواصله منذ اكثر من شهرين طهران تلجا
الى اقناعي زعامات معتدله بمطالبه
المحتاجين بانهاء حراكههم ولكنها فشلت
تقول صحيفه وصفت جورنال التي اعتبرت ان
الحراك هو تحدي الابرز للنظام في تاريخه
الممتد
لثلاثه واربعين سنه وفي التفاصيل كشفت
الصحيفه الامريكيه عن عجز النظام الايراني
الاستعانه بمن يوصفنا بالمعتدلين من اهل
الخميني ونفس جاني وحتى خاتمي بعد اقصائهم
في السنوات الاخيره تمهيدا لخلافه ونقل
الاطعمه الطالعين لم تسمىهم ان الامين
العام للمجلس الاعلى للامن القومي على
شامخاني سال ممثلين الاسرتين ان يخاطبوا
المحتاجين ويطالبوهم بوقفه حراقهم واعيدا
بتخفيف القيود الاجتماعيه في حال توقف
الحراك لكن هؤلاء رفضوا الاستجابه النظام
الايراني ايضا انتقادات من داخل البرلمان
حيث طلب نائب ايراني بمسائله الرئيس
ابراهيم رئيسي ووزير داخليته على خلفيه
استخدام الذخائر الحيه ضد المحتشين بعد ما
اخذت الاضطرابات المواكبه للحراك
الاحتجاجيه ابعادا جديده معا انضمام سائقي
الشاحنات الى اضراب عمال مصانع وشركات في
قطاع النفط فيما يواصل المحتاجون حركهم
باشكال مختلفه في تحدي للاجراءات الامنيه
المشدده في انحاء البلاد فل نتابع
مشاهدينا هذه الاحتجاجات من مترو طهران
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
طهران بدورها تقول ان لديها ادله على تورط
دول غربيه في الاحتجاجات التي تعمل
تقصي الحقائق التي وافق المجلس حقوق
الانسان تابع للامم المتحده على تشكيلها
بشان الاحتجاجات التي ذهب ضحيتها نحو 450
قتيلا بينهم 63 طفلا منذ بدايه الاحتجاجات
في السادسه عشر من سبتمبر الماضي وفقا
مجموعه نشطاء لحقوق الانسان في ايران
دعونا ايضا مشاهدينا نتابع بعضا من الرسوم
المعبره عن احتجاجات
[موسيقى]